Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on.
Guys. This is Rob and, uh, we are picking back up with the juggernaut,
the juggernaut series over here at Marvel comics.
And I know this is something that we don't,
we kind of cover not really inconsistently, but Marvel does it once a month.
Right. So we kind of have to just wait it out a little bit. And at the moment,
right now, I believe we're at issue number four.
And I think we have another week or two before issue.
Number five comes out maybe a little bit longer than that.
What this does is this kind of picks up off the heels of the last story that we
did, right. In the sense that, uh, we ended up learning that Arnhem Zola,
the one time member of Hydra who's long since been defected from the group and
kind of doing his own thing had basically been kidnapping people who were
mutants and then more or less experimenting on them. Right?
So in a lot of ways kind of taking over the role that was previously assigned to
Mr. Sinister in the X-Men comics. Uh, now the funny thing about this,
this was kind of interesting here is that Arnhem Zola, at least as we're told,
is operating out of an old factor three base. Now factor three,
this was kind of a kind of wild here. Factor three.
This is an old school organization, right?
So factor three was created in uncanny X-Men number 28.
I want to say,
I think it was just X-Men number 28 back in the day by Roy Thomas. Um,
they're an old school enemy of the X-Men. They weren't really like a big deal,
right? I mean,
they were kind of a group that was introduced before the era of Claremont when
like groups were a lot more nuanced, a lot more, uh, subversive and,
and really a lot more dangerous, you know, in, in the,
the Claremont era on Kenny X-Men,
but it is kind of cool to see an old throwback.
But the idea is that as soon as juggernaut gets in here,
he's immediately attacked by Primus. Now, prime,
this goes all the way back to the old captain America and Falcon comics back in
1977, right? So this is not a new concept, but prime is,
as it existed was really just kind of a wholesale creation by Arnhem Zola,
not really a modification of an existing person,
but really just a complete and total creation,
but the idea behind Primus and really what made privacy so dangerous in the
old-school Marvel comics.
And even now to a degree is the fact that he's really just a malleable plastic
character, right. He just kind of this Android,
they can essentially do whatever it is that he needs to do in order to overcome
an enemy in terms of adjusting himself. Right.
So think of it as something very similar to Mr.
Fantastic of the fantastic four now,
for the most part with juggernaut facing off against this guy,
it's like being tied up in string. And in fact,
when he's basically captured by primates it's because prime has kind of turns
itself into a sort of gelatinous state and then bonds itself to two juggernaut,
which basically sort of solidifies it, right. It just kind of keeps him in case,
but following him being knocked out,
we kind of get this little bit of a throwback, uh, about,
about a few months ago. We're not given an actual definitive date,
but at some point a few months ago that with Cain Marco showing back up and then
trying to, you know, having the,
the Crimson bands and then from there trying to reaccess his, uh,
his power as the John or not,
he ends up breaking into a storage facility that belongs to one.
Now the one stands for office of national emergency.
And this was an organization that largely Rose to prominence in the aftermath of
decimation of really during the events of decimation,
the aftermath of house of ant, right?
When the mutant population lost its powers or at least 98% of the mutant
population losses powers the office of national basically reactivated the
Sentinel program, but they were Madison. The other thing they did too,
is they kind of made the X-Men prisoners, not directly,
but in so far as what was left of the mutant population resigned itself to the
grounds of the Xavier Institute. And then under Cyclops,
basically nobody was allowed to leave right in the sentinels basically existed
there under the auspices of, Hey,
we're going to protect you guys from various threats out there all the,
while the X-Men were basically prisoners,
they just weren't really allowed to go anywhere. Right?
So it was kind of the X-Men turning to an authority figure to keep them safe all
the while making themselves prisoners of that authority figure and just not
realizing it. And so following that with Cain, Marko basically re accessing the,
the, the kind of shards of the Crimson Jim of Ciroc,
and then kind of reactivating his juggernaut powers through the Crimson bands
that he currently possesses. He's met by the disembodied voice of, uh,
of sort of rock himself.
And so we're gonna kind of jump forward here for a second,
technically in the story,
but what it does is it yanks him directly to the Crimson dimension right now,
one of the things to understand when it comes to sit a rack and we really
haven't covered his character all too much,
but one of the important things to understand when it comes to [inaudible] is in
his own dimension, he's wildly powerful. And in fact,
there's been multiple instances in the case of Marvel comics,
where it's been stated that his Ciroc were to leave his dimension and show up in
the main Marvel universe with all of his powers intact,
basically operating at 100% of his powers. Nobody could stop him, right? Not,
Dormamuu not Dr. Strange nobody, right guys, just a whole nother level of power.
It's really insane, but such as it is,
he's confined really to his own Crimson dimension and can't really leave.
And that's where juggernaut comes into play, right?
Juggernauts kind of the extension of back on earth and allowing him to kind of
do his own thing.
But the crazy thing about this is that what we're told here is traditionally the
armor given to juggernaut and the empowerment of the,
the Crimson gym basically anchors him to sit a rock, right?
It's how it set a rock was able to act through him over the years, uh,
during the eighth day event, for example,
when Siracha basically took total control or at least gave juggernaut almost
100% of his power and the juggernaut went forward just on a whole new level of
strength that we never really seen before, uh, that was all sit around,
acting through him.
The difference is that these bands that he has largely seem to be bands that are
tied to the bands that Dr strange uses, right?
The Crimson bands of sit or act because of her Dr. Strange,
using that spell before they're essentially seeming to be tied to Dr. Strange
his power in some way, we're not giving a definitive explanation here.
The important thing about this though, is that the gyms itself,
because they were kind of destroyed, but now reconstituted,
what it does is it allows juggernaut to go forward as a person who acts
autonomously of Ciroc, basically,
meaning he's not anchored to them or anchored to him.
So when Ciroc says like you have now returned to me as my,
my earthly avatar go forward and do my bidding through response to gender,
not is, you know, that's not going to happen.
I've not been whisked here to your realm. I'm here in a mind state,
but physically I'm still back on earth. I'll no longer you do your bidding.
I'll do whatever I want to do right now. It really kind of begs a question.
This is what we do not get an answer to. It really kind of begs the question.
If juggernauts powered by the Crimson, Jim was sitter at, uh,
and he goes forward wearing the Crimson bands and the Crimson bans are basically
a source of power linked to Dr. Strange bicycle rack. Then effectively,
he's still anchored to him. No, he doesn't necessarily have to do his bidding,
but by all standards of measurement, his can be taken away.
That's where the question becomes. If that's the case, why is it not habit,
right? Why didn't sit around,
just strip him of his power and all were given as this kind of loose
explanation. I'm not directly anchored to you anymore.
So what it seems like is for whatever reason,
the power of Ciroc is still confined to the Crimson gym,
but the Crimson gym cannot be accessed by Ciroc, right?
So you basically cannot cut the juggernaut off from a source of power.
So to give this a more tangible perspective,
it's like cutting off a person's hand, right? It doesn't belong to them anymore.
It's just in the possession of whoever it is that has that hand.
They can't do anything with it.
They can't move their fingers or anything like that.
That's basically what it looks like,
which is kind of interesting because it seems to defy this omnipotent power of
Cinerama. But it's also cool because it moves Jaeger,
not into being in a different position. Now, again, it's the nature of comics.
Everything that changes goes back to the being the way that it was before.
So somewhere along the line something's going to happen and juggernaut is going
to go back to being as old self, right? It's the nature of comics,
nothing stays changed for long, right?
Everything just always goes back to the status quo.
But for this time that we get it, it looks like it's pretty cool. Right?
So kind of jumping back to,
to where he's basically been captured and confined inside of this, uh, this,
this, you know, base of operations for Arnhem Zola,
of course you have diesel jump in and that's where things get interesting here,
because one of the things to understand this is more of an interim comic, right?
So there's not a whole lot of action going on here.
We do get kind of a return or at least a new status quo for juggernaut.
But beyond that, there's not a whole lot happening.
Instead of DSL basically jumps out of this, this, you know, uh,
this helicopter uses her power to kind of slow herself down.
So she doesn't smash into the ground in the mountains and die.
And then from there, Arnhem,
Zola makes his presence known and basically tells us what we already know.
Right. That for years he's been experimenting on mutants because mutans are now
considered to be a rare commodity, right? That were, there was no Precoa,
there was no centralized location where by all mutants existed and nobody could
access it. Beaton's used to be all over the place, right.
They were just in different places around the world,
just kind of making their living and doing their thing.
And it was very easy to access any mutant and basically kidnapped them,
experiment on them. And that's what you wanted to do.
But now that all the mutants are essentially under the purview of Coca-Cola and
the protection of the Island and the power of those who were on the Island.
One doesn't simply just walk into Coca-Cola,
you'll just simply go in there and then take a mutant and leave.
It doesn't really work that way. Right? I mean,
you'd likely get yourself killed doing it.
And so mutants are now a highly sought after commodity, like adamantium,
the whole point behind this is they're a rare commodity.
And so Arnhem Zola able to get his hands on a mutant and then in turn mess with
their DNA. And then, you know,
kind of sell that off to the highest bidder is a huge source of income.
That kind of seems to be what's going on here now for its part,
when diesel goes against Primus,
she's nowhere near prepared for that level of power.
And so she's ultimately conquered as well. And so with that,
being the case and juggernauts seeing what's happening and realizing they're
basically going to kill her and then kind of extract your DNA, break it down,
figure out how her powers work, find a way to duplicate it,
and then sell that off to somebody.
He of course smashes out of his containment cell.
And that immediately goes after Primus. Now, when that happens,
primacy of course, attacks juggernaut,
but juggernaut does one of those big thunder claps and then basically shatters
privates into a whole bunch of different pieces, right?
It doesn't really seem to kill them as much as incapacitate them,
but then from there, he goes directly after Arnhem Zola.
Now when he frees diesel, she of course goes after Arnhem, Zola as well,
and then seeks to destroy him only for us to find out that Arnhem Zola has been
conscripted, right?
He's been forced into servitude by some other organization out there that's
really pulling the strings. And so he's not really the mastermind here.
There's a much bigger plan of foot and there's a much bigger organization out
there. Again, it's an internal comment.
This is the empire strikes back of the story, right.
It just it's more informational than anything else.
It doesn't really have a whole lot of action.
And there's certainly no conclusion here.
It doesn't really kind of give us the idea that there's a much bigger situation
going on. So again, it's cool. You know, I, I dig it.
It's certainly one of those who probably could have coupled with the next video
with the next comic that came out and it probably would have done some good in
terms of having a little more going on in this particular story. But you know,
this is also a little important here because having it as its own individual
story gives us the ability to understand better what's going on as opposed to
having to rush through it and then making up for things later on down the road.
Right? So, uh, again, not a whole lot doing here,
but it probably does have a few bits of important information that'll become
relevant later on. But if you guys are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys at the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
Bruce.